[Music]
so
hello
[Music]
so
you
[Music]
do
hey everybody welcome to the table
i was just looking outside my front
window and it is really snowing now
is it snowing where you are if you're
anywhere in texas it's either snowing
now or it will snow
gosh this is crazy it looks like a snow
globe outside
i've got my tea i hope you have your
warm beverage
um or underneath the blanket or cozied
up somewhere
where it is warm and safe well welcome
so glad you're here tonight with us um
it's a great night
to be together with your church friends
so comment down below let us know where
you're watching from let us know that
you're here we would love to connect
with you
and tonight i have just a couple of
announcements
ways to get connected here at the table
where everyone has a seat at the table
it's like product placement isn't it
anyways
uh two weeks from today sunday february
28th
save the date we are going to do
our bi-annual state of the table meeting
it's kind of like the state of the union
only on a much much
smaller scale so we'll be talking about
our plans for transitioning to in-person
services
our goals and vision for the year and
you don't have to be a member to
be a part of this meeting it's for
anyone who cares about the table wants
to hear more
about us and just to be a part so that's
happening
in two weeks and uh it will happen right
after the service on february 28th so
right around 6 15.
we'll do that so i hope you'll join us
secondly
uh the book club did you know the table
has a book club
and the next book selection has been
made it's a really really good one
i actually have it more product
placement
cast by isabelle wilkerson this is
the next book club selection it's
amazing i just started it this morning
i'm about two chapters in
it's an excellent read it was number one
on the new york bestseller list
lots of top books of 2020 lists that
this book has been a part of
um so so relevant for where we are right
now in our world
and i think it should be required
reading at least at the table
our book club is led by sarah johns
and glenda bayern and uh
we would love for you to be a part of
this next month's book club
and because cast is uh it's a bigger
book it's a pretty dense read but it's
it's fairly easy to to read through
there's just a lot of information
um we're gonna split it up in sections
so
on saturday march 13th we're gonna
gather together as a book club and
discuss
the first three parts of the book
so this is open to anyone who wants to
read the book be a part of this
discussion
it's going to be a really really good
and i want to say one thing about book
clubs
they are not just for those who identify
as women
they're for everybody on the gender
spectrum so let's just buck the
stereotype
that book clubs are for women because
that's just not true
it's kind of like people are surprised
that i love sports and i love watching
the super bowl for the actual game and
not the commercials
so let's just the stereotypes and
guys this is a personal challenge to you
to get the bookcast read it and join in
the book club
it's for everyone so i hope you'll make
a point to join in
if you want more information about the
book club you can email
sarah at s s-a-r-a
sarah at thetabletx.org or you can
comment below
and we'll get you more information on
the book club
all right so as we transition into
worship for tonight
um i thought you know with most of us
home um you know it's just naturally a
time to
uh slow down a bit and sometimes
our bodies can slow down you know we can
be sitting or laying down or wherever
you find yourself right now but
our minds aren't necessarily
slowing down um so
i thought we could take some time right
now just to
center ourselves take some time to
intentionally slow down
our heartbeats our bodies any racing
thoughts
and just take a moment so
if you're game please do this with me
just close your eyes
wherever you are close your eyes
take a deep breath in
let it out again
deep expanding breath in
let it out very slowly
just feel yourself start to relax
god we center on you and remember
that you are the source of peace
of love and of hope
be with us and among us tonight as we
worship together
in spirit and god please be with those
that find themselves affected by
homelessness
this week god please give them warm
shelter
nourishing food connection with others
and safety from the elements
we center on you tonight we remember
who you are and god that you
are faithful and you can be trusted help
us to
become ever more aware of that tonight
and in the days ahead
in jesus name amen
[Music]
the seasons
so why should i
take care of me they take good care of
me
you know what i need
[Music]
take good
forgiveness
[Music]
take care of me you know
no matter
[Music]
take care of me
i know there must be more
[Music]
you take good care of me
take good care of me you know what i
need before
[Music]
no matter what the future brings
take care of me
[Music]
go come to the
altar the father's
arms are open white
forgiveness was bought with
the precious blood of jesus christ
[Music]
have you come to the end of yourself
jesus is calling
[Music]
oh come to alter
blood of jesus christ
[Music]
leave behind your regrets and mistakes
come today there's no reason to wait
jesus is calling
[Music]
bring your sorrows and trade them with
joy
from
[Music]
the father's arms are open
wide forgiveness sparked with
the precious blood of jesus christ will
come to alter
the father's arms are open wide
forgiveness spot with
the precious blood of jesus christ
jesus christ
oh what a savior
isn't he wonderful
hallelujah christ
is risen
[Music]
let's bow down before him
for he is lord of
all sing hallelujah
christ is risen
[Music]
oh what
isn't is wonderful
say hallelujah bow down before
him for he is lord of all
sing hallelujah
there you cross as you wait for the
crown
tell the world of this
[Music]
thanks gary for sharing that with us
hello everybody um i'm mindy
and i wanted to um play beat on my
vision this week before brett shares his
thoughts with us for a while the lyrics
of this song
are really what i love because um it's
kind of talking about the way
that um the way that jesus
really changes the way that we see
things the way that we interact with
each other the way that we relate
to people and to our world when we are
living a life that's kind of following
after his ways
um he transforms us he changes things
and i hope that you guys are able to
join
in however you're comfortable and we're
going to go ahead and
do that song now
be thou my vision
o lord of my
heart not be
all else
[Music]
or by my
waking or sleeping
thy presence thy life
[Music]
and thou my true
me lord thou
my
[Music]
and i win
may i reach heavens
join is
be my vision
[Music]
still be my vision
thank you god continue to transform us
continue to enter into every
cell every portion of our life the way
that we interact the way that we see
things
yeah keep doing your work in us we love
you
amen
hey good evening everyone
grace and peace thank you mindy gary and
karen
and uh man it's great to be with y'all
oh my gosh i need a haircut so much i'm
seeing myself in this video
so it's outrageous um so okay let's not
be distracted
um y'all it's so good to be with you
i'm very excited so we are in this is
the the sixth and the final
uh part of our series titled epiphany
a radical invitation and uh
next week we'll be in a new series and
in a new season the christian calendar
is the season of lent
um which is a time basically of heart
and soul preparation
for good friday uh that of course is the
day where we remember the crucifixion of
jesus and then eventually leads into
easter
so that's kind of kicking off next week
um but tonight we are still in the
season of epiphany
and so the title of my message is
how to stay warm okay that's a lie it is
not it's called
called the transfiguration that's
it i guess probably scott was putting it
up so he already you already knew that
um it is as karen has mentioned others i
mentioned
oh my gosh y'all it's so cold in texas
it's ridiculous what this is why we all
moved here
to like avoid this and tomorrow i think
it's a low of one
just so wrong so okay so not how to stay
warm
called to transfiguration uh and so we
have two texts uh from scripture tonight
the first is from mark chapter nine
verses two through eight uh and
the second is first john three one
through two uh one through two
and um our very own cody jacobs is gonna
do those scripture readings so sarah
will also um
she'll post those in the comments uh
just just to make sure
you can uh track and follow along so
cody take it away
good evening table family my name is
cody and i'll be reading you two
scriptures on tonight
the first one is mark chapter nine
verses two three
and it reads after six days jesus took
peter
james and john with him and led them up
behind mountain where they were all
alone
there he was transfigured before them
his clothes became
dazzling white wider than anyone in the
world could bleach them
and there appeared before them elijah
and moses
who were talking with jesus peter said
to jesus
rabbi it is good for us to be here let
us put up three shelters one for you
one for moses and one for elijah he did
not know what to say
they were so frightened then a cloud
appeared
and covered them and a voice came from
the cloud this is my son
whom i love listen to him suddenly
when they looked around they no longer
saw anyone
with them except jesus
the second verse is first john chapter 3
verse 20 and it reads
if our hearts condemn us we know that
god is greater than
our hearts and he knows everything
thank you
thank you cody so i want to begin by
going back
to um mark chapter nine
so um this is this is that's the story
of the transfiguration of jesus
and it's it's a moment where the
divinity of jesus
a divinity normally concealed
is suddenly very evident it just
radiates forth so in a different telling
of this exact same story in the gospel
of matthew
um he adds the additional detail that
jesus faced it actually
shone like the sun so
kind of what we're getting is this
picture of christ
as as completely flooded with the spirit
of god
so much so that his face and his clothes
uh clothes are just bursting with light
now what i want to point out here
is that this is not a light from outside
of jesus shining down upon him it is not
an
external glory an external
um beauty shining on him like a
spotlight or something
um that would not be a transfiguration
transfiguration
is when the glory within
a person is suddenly revealed
so transfiguration it's an unveiling i
want to give you this definition
transfiguration is where the glory of
god
hidden inside suddenly manifests
outside so it's a move from the internal
to the external so what mark 9 is
describing
is an absolutely extraordinary
transfiguration experience
because here's the truth the truth is
that jesus
was always radiant jesus was
always a profoundly uh spiritual
being the the son of god uh like yes he
was flesh
but he was also divine right so so he
was
always bursting with the glory and the
beauty of god
that was always already his identity but
suddenly the disciples by the grace of
god
had a moment where the scales fell from
their eyes
so to speak and suddenly they saw jesus
as the father
sees jesus in other words they were
privileged to see the deep
truth of who jesus always
was now where i think we can go a bit
wrong
is that we hear a story like this and
what we
think to ourselves is something along
the lines
of of this like well well of course
this transfiguration happened to jesus
because well he's the son of god
he is you know as the scriptures say the
perfect image
and representation of god so
you might be thinking yourself well
brett i'm not too shocked that a moment
like that could occur
for jesus i'm not too shocked that jesus
could be
transfigured but
when we hear that story what we don't
think to ourselves
is uh that is my
future that is my calling
that that is the deeper reality within
myself and
all created things not to be clear that
we are like literally the son of god or
um that we are literally god but i mean
all the language of the new testament is
that god
is within us that that we
ourselves uh are you might say shining
with divinity
um that that we are dripping with god's
spirit
and that in that my calling and your
calling is to step
into that more and more and more every
day
that i am called to be radiant with the
love of god
where when people interact with me they
walk away and say to themselves
i haven't felt that close to god in a
long
time that's our future that's our
calling
uh but we don't we don't tend to think
like that do we
but if you reflect on it i think we
actually
um have glimpses just little
inklings of transfiguration
in other words um little moments where
the glory
of someone or something of creation it
kind of
bursts forth it like radiates out and i
think we actually have this on a
somewhat consistent
um basis these kinds of experiences like
have you ever been
um looking at someone normally it's
someone you know well perhaps your child
or a spouse or a friend
and you're you're looking at them and
suddenly
you realize that for months and maybe
years
you have not really been seeing them
like you haven't been seeing uh the
glory within them
i mean like perhaps when you first met
them there was something about them that
was
beyond description but with the passing
of
time that way of seeing them it it
started to fade
but suddenly you're sitting across like
the room
and perhaps the light from the window is
falling across their face just so
or maybe they don't even realize
anyone's looking at them and so they're
just perfectly natural perfectly
themselves and suddenly
it's like your eyes open wide because
they look both beautiful
and strange to you you're like
wait what when when did they change
it's as though there is a glory in them
that has been hidden from your gaze but
suddenly
you see them or perhaps you've had
this experience in nature i mean it can
be very much the same thing the the dew
on a blade of grass the deep purple of a
flower
the quiet of a forest or as we've
experienced
the last 24 hours the piece of snow
falling
and and you maybe you've walked by that
grass or that flower or in that forest
or you've seen snow like a thousand
times
but suddenly you see it
like you really see it and it is shining
not not necessarily literally like oh my
gosh it's so bright but
but in the sense of like somehow it's
being it's
essence it's god connectedness just
jumps out at you have you ever had this
experience man i wish i was in person so
i could see your faces because i'm
i'm pretty convinced people have these
kinds of you know spiritual encounters
where it's like
things you see suddenly um more deeply
into someone or
something it's this moment of
transfiguration where where the thing is
shining forth god
is um almost like smiling at you through
the the person placer thing um and by
the way artists
have a gift for having these types of
experiences and then
translating them into great art great
poetry painting music
etc it's it's the transcendent it's the
moment where heaven
touches earth the moment where we get a
glimpse
just a glimpse of transfiguration
now just to be clear i'm i'm not trying
to give an overly rosy view like
specifically of humanity
uh because if we're to trust the bible
here's the crazy truth about human
beings
we have the capacity within us
to radiate heaven
or hell to become the most
depraved kind of person
dripping with the downright demonic or
beautiful souls
the light and love of god everywhere we
go
but again back to my original point we
don't tend to think
we have that kind of calling or capacity
um that's just for jesus uh which is
is why i wanna uh come to this verse
this is um
first john chapter three verse two it
says dear friends
now we are children of god and what we
will
be has not yet been made
known what we will be has not yet been
made
known in other words you do not yet know
you do not grasp who you really
are like who you really are you you
think you know
but but like you don't get it and
furthermore you do not yet know
you do not grasp who other people are
you see for for orthodox christianity
i'm thinking here primarily of
of the eastern orthodox wing of the
church
uh i'll talk in a bit about kind of the
west and versus east
um but particularly the eastern orthodox
wing of the church
um it the the idea of the
transfiguration of jesus
is not simply a story about how
amazing or remarkable jesus is though i
mean it is that
it is also a scene it's understood as a
foreshadowing
a a hint a picture
of what is going to happen to us
in fact you might say uh that this is
what it means
to be saved it's kind of funny how we
throw around that phrase so easily i
mean if you're in at least in texas
texas we throw that around a lot here in
the south you hear you know a lot of
a lot of phrases like you know you need
to be saved brother have you been saved
sister
and uh i think i think of that movie
that came out like i don't know 15
20 years ago did y'all see this one
saved
oh man oh
it's kind of painful to watch um because
it's too
accurate about our kind of religious
hokiness at times
and it's it's kind of pointing out this
this kind of hokey simplistic
version of saved uh and and i say
hoagie's listing
at one level um i mean it kind of is but
it's it's kind of getting at something
though that is in
um in i think i'll argue in a moment
it's really kind of part of the more
western
um kind of christianity uh so
usually you know we throw that term
around uh saved
what what is meant are normally three
things so this is kind of a simplified
kind of slightly reductionistic
version um that's but that's very
popular in the christian
west uh and we're about to get quite
theological for just don't worry this
won't be too long i don't want to lose
anyone
um but you know three to four minutes
kind of hang with me um
i am going somewhere with this okay so
salvation in the christian west what
does it mean to be saved in the
christian
west uh and and just to be clear you
know
by west i mean roman catholicism and
protestantism which is basically most of
you know american christianity so
salvation the christian west it means a
few things a
forgiveness right so when when you say
you need to be saved
what what you mean is um you through the
cross
you need to um repent and then receive
the forgiveness of christ
right so you need to save it implies
kind of a forgiveness
um be changed status
status so as a forgiven person
i switch categories i go from the
category
of lost to the category of saved
can you hear the kind of the change
status there lost to save in other words
from kind of hell-bound
to heaven-bound right kind of from enemy
of god
to friend or son or daughter of god so
it's about this
this change status so it starts with
forgiveness then i receive this change
status uh and then we kind of go into
point c would be something like maybe
moral betterment like
now i am saved so um i
will you know i'll try to live better
because you know i'm so
i'm so thankful to to christ um
and and of course something here is kind
of missing and
and i we might think of it like this so
again in the christian west
um the focus is on really that point b
that change
status that's kind of the linchpin
that's like where you know everything's
happening
because to be saved meant you know yes
you were forgiven and that when you died
you knew where you were going and then
in the meantime uh you were
kind of going to stay away from the
dancing and the drugging and the
drinking
and you're gonna comb your hair and go
to church on sundays
right because you you were once lost now
you have been found you were an enemy
now you're a friend so like this is kind
of what it means
so that's kind of popularly you know
what it has meant to be
saved um now theologians
in the west they would say well it's
about more than this it's like a deeper
sanctification of things
but uh you know often though this is
kind of how it got
boiled down like you know the most
important pers
or question you could ask a person was
you know if you died tonight
do you know that you know that you know
you would go to heaven
right that's the emphasis that's change
status that's that's
where it kind of um all boiled down to
all right so
where i um basically i think the
christian east
is much more helpful here um
eastern orthodoxy is is i think quite
helpful so in the christian east
um this is salvation so a forgiveness
that's still
a big part of it right through cross and
resurrection um i
am forgiven and reconciled to the father
yep
that's for sure true um but then b
this is the lord it's a little bit
different um changed substance substance
so the emphasis isn't so much on
status instead when i say substance i'm
talking about the
us like who we are our essence so the
idea really is that the spirit of god
transforms and recreates our physical
spiritual um substance or or essence the
the core of who we
are it's it's a deep profound
transformation
of the body soul mind like the whole
person
and this by the way is where spiritual
disciplines come in
right and and so we engage not because
we want to like change ourselves by like
trying real hard
rather spiritual disciplines like i'm
thinking you know prayer scripture
reading fasting
silence journaling you know all the
things these are ways
that we become more open and aware of
this
work of the spirit that god is always
already trying to do
in us but it's a deep deep change
it's not just about status just like
well yeah now i'm saved
like it's it's this substantive change
and it's very participatory in the sense
of i mean it's grace in the sense that
it takes god's initiation it's god
kind of um uh being the energy behind it
but we
have to say yes right he doesn't like
force it on us
uh we have to join in with it okay so i
realize that perhaps i've lost some of
you
so let me kind of sum this up by by
putting it this way so in in
um i think what i'm naming with this
substance thing
is that i am called to more than
forgiveness
you and i we are called to more
than getting my life right
i'm called to more even than taking up
my cross
in the sense of a life of sacrificial
love and service i'm not saying you're
called less than that or you know forget
that cross stuff that's not what i'm
saying
i'm saying more that's a step in the
path
so i'm called to more than forgiveness
more than getting my life right even
more than taking up my cross i am
ultimately called
to transfiguration the place where
every cell of my body radiates
the divine life can i get a name
right and and make no mistake about it
um that's a high calling
and and honestly this is where bumper
sticker theology
oh oh it tends to fall you know pretty
painfully short here's uh this is a
classic one i think
um this has been around for a while
maybe you've seen this one
um christians aren't perfect
just forgiven have you seen that bumper
sticker christians aren't perfect
just forgiven all right so the problem
in that sentence
um is the word uh just because of course
i mean it's true christians are perfect
um but but it's it's almost as though
that is the end point right i'm ju
i'm just forgiven in other words just
change status
just to change status that's all i've
just i'm just i just went into the
category of
forgiven there's nothing else different
about me
can you hear the weirdness going on
there like we're just the forgiven
people
there is no difference between us and
you know anyone else there's no changed
substance no spiritual transformation i
am
merely forgiven so the bumper sticker
seems to imply
don't get your hopes up that i'll be
driving differently
than anyone else i'll be
just as rude angry embittered
um i mean it seems to me that's sort of
the the pitiful
essence of that bumper sticker uh so the
problem
there is uh i mean basically it would be
the problems the bible
um the apostle paul and other new
testament writers
they would want to say much more than uh
i'm not perfect just forgiven so here's
paul this is second corinthians 3 18.
and we all he writes to the church who
with unveiled faces
contemplate the lord's glory anytime you
hear the word glory in the
bible by the way think of the word
beauty beauty we contemplate the lord's
glorious beauty he says we are being
transformed
into his image
with ever increasing glory
which comes from the lord who is the
spirit in other words
the glory of christ it is slowly
working its way through through the um
by grace and through the presence of the
holy spirit
it's his glory is becoming my glory your
glory or again in the same letter of
second corinthians but chapter five
verse 17 he says therefore if anyone is
in christ he or implied there is she is
a new
creation the old has passed away
behold the new has come
can you hear the changed substance there
not just status here's ephesians 3 17-19
he says that you church you being rooted
and grounded in
love may you have the strength to
comprehend with all the saints what is
the breadth
and the length and the height and depth
and to know the love of christ that
surpasses knowledge
that you here it is that you may be
filled
with all the fullness of god
okay so i'll be honest this probably
means
uh many of us have been praying poorly
i don't know about you but i often find
myself praying you know things like this
lord
um you know help me to have a good day
and
uh help my kids to be good and stuff uh
which is i mean that's okay oh you know
it's not that's not a bad prayer
but when was the last time you or i
prayed today lord may i be
filled with the fullness of your divine
life may the transfiguration that
happened in
jesus may it begin to happen in me
okay or finally here's a passage this is
second peter
chapter one verses three through four
his divine power
has given us everything we need for a
godly life through our knowledge of him
who called us by his
own glory there's that word again and
goodness
through these he has given us his very
great and precious promises
so that through them you may participate
in the divine nature
participate in the divine nature what is
that talking about
it's transfiguration it's it's new
creation
it's it's what is known in christian
theology as as
theosis you are called to participate
to become immersed in the divine
life in fact the early church fathers
they just came out and called it
divinization like basically becoming um
god-eyes divinized um now to be clear
they didn't mean it in the sense that
you or i
were like yes we will become god right
okay obviously not
um but it's it's in the sense that our
life your life my life so
thoroughly um fuses with god's life
through the holy spirit
that it's hard to tell where you end
and god begins
now you might say
okay so do you mean like in heaven like
when when i die then i will be
transfigured then i will
experience this union oneness with god
and christ but in the meantime
i'm not perfect just forgiven
um you know yes and no i mean
yes in the sense of um first john 3
right you do not yet know what you will
be
in this life we we see through a glass
darkly paul says in this life we are
veiled our glory and really all of
creation's glory
is like christ when he was on earth it's
it's sort of
hidden you might even use language like
fallen um
right so um so
so yes in that sense but no in the sense
that
like well all this stuff brett's been
talking about that's for heaven uh no no
that that's where you'd misunderstand
instead the idea
is that this process of union with god
while it will not find its endpoint
until the next life
it begins in this one
it begins today
now uh i have no idea how
all of this is hitting you um but
perhaps you're thinking like oh my gosh
um this is just a lot i don't
i don't even know like where to begin
like brett what
what do i do how do i inch towards
transfiguration towards this ongoing
experience the presence of god that
seems like
a very tall task uh and and i do want to
respond to that because i don't want
this to just be like high falutin
theology
um where we say very lofty things about
jesus and then we
say and we're called to you know the
grace of god and the spirit similar
things
um i don't want to just stay there
kind of you know 10 000 feet in the air
because i actually believe
it is the most practical thing in the
world
that transfiguration it is literally
about how you relate
to um the people in your household
which you're gonna get a lot of time
with over the next um
few days if you're in texas um
and honestly it's about how you engage
your work um how you
speak with people um and interact with
them i mean
everything so so in closing let me give
you kind of a
framework for this transfiguration
process i love how the christian writer
cynthia borgol she put it like this she
said the recipe
for spiritual transformation is
basically the same
all over surrender
attention compassion
that's a beautiful summary surrender
let me give you just just a little bit
on each of these so surrender what is
that
what does that mean um there must be a
sense
in which if we want to start down the
road of
really um being connected to god
and entering into this transfiguration
process there must be a sense in which
we begin to say
um not my will lord
not my genius ego driven plans
lord your will in every moment
your will god play through me move
through me
fill me with your spirit guide me um
it's a saying no to my ego and a yes to
you
i mean i think of of jesus who said i i
don't
say anything except what i hear the
father saying
i don't do anything except what i what i
um hear the father or see the father
doing
right that's that's surrender so we
start there surrender
uh second attention another word here
might be awareness so much of our life
is spent on autopilot isn't it
i mean like the way some spiritual
writers put it was they say we aren't
awake so to speak we aren't aware
so we've got to start paying attention
we've got to start entering into
awareness start
um start watching yourself paying
attention tuning in to yourself what
what are you thinking right now what are
you what are you um
feeling right every everything you do be
aware
god awareness begins with self-awareness
because what happens is you become aware
that the source of your true
self is is god right it's you are in god
you are
in christ and so what happens is you'll
begin
to tune more and more and more into the
fact that
god is present
always god is present there is nowhere
you can go
that god is not already there right so
it's attention
it's it's awareness of god's presence
third compassion uh this
is the idea of great love
great love um which by the way is always
the answer
i heard a teacher giving a lecture
recently and he said
the answer is always great love no
matter what you ask
the answer is always great love it's
sort of like uh in sunday school
if you had this experience growing up um
the answer is always jesus
if the teacher asks a question in sunday
school and you say jesus
you're nearly always correct and in a
similar way in whatever situation
um you're facing the answer is almost
always
great love like i mean whatever it is
you say like oh my spouse and i we're
just at the end of our
rope i i don't even i don't even know
how to relate to him i don't even know
how to relate to her
anymore great love
great love uh or you say my kids like
oh my kids are just driving me bananas
how do i parent wild banshees
great love great love you say my boss is
the
worst how how do i interact with him or
her like i don't
do great love it feels like my life just
it just has no meaning like when i wake
up in the morning
what what should i do with myself
great love great love
surrender attention compassion
this is what it means to be saved it's
more than forgiveness it's more than get
your life right it's
more than take up your cross it is a
call
to transfiguration where every cell
of your body radiates the divine life
that's our calling let me pray for us
lord jesus
we want to know you we want to enter
into
your presence god we want every cell of
our body to
radiate your life so god would you do
that deep deep work in us we say yes to
it and god we want to do our part
we want to join in
god so help us to be faithful
to surrender faithful to
attention faithful to compassion
and may you overtake us may your spirit
fill us
do your good work we love you in the
name of jesus i pray
amen
[Music]
from the clouds you speak
what was there now
is seen
jesus the image of
[Applause]
the invisible
god
divinity confirmed
in the transfigured
a kingdom once concealed
now on earth is
revealed
holy is the lord revealed before my
eyes and my burning heart can scarcely
take it
[Music]
as in behold your beauty with unworthy
eyes the only song
my soul can find to see
is hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
[Applause]
my kingdom
[Music]
you
holy is the lord revealed before my
eyes and my burning heart can scarcely
take it in
with is eyes
and the only song my soul can find to
see
is hallelujah
[Music]
now i know
i have seen
your glory that cannot be
unseen i
am changed and changing still
[Music]
and i have seen
i am changed
and changing still
[Music]
and my burning heart can scarcely take
it inside behold your beauty with
eyes and the only song
i so can find to see
[Music]
is
hallelujah my
king
[Music]
hallelujah
everything is transformed by you
[Music]
everything
is different because of you
[Music]
hallelujah
thanks mindy thanks brett for a great
message
and thank you to everybody who
contributed to the service tonight
uh gary and cody and behind the scenes
we also have
scott johnson and sarah johns and
speaking of the two of them scott and
sarah they both
asked me where i got my mug this is not
uh this is not table merch um it's
actually
well not our table um it's from magnolia
table
but i love what it says friend of mine
gave this to me for my birthday
earlier this year and i love that it
says where everyone has a seat at the
table
so if you want one of these you'll have
to get it
online at the magnolia table shop maybe
at some point we'll have
a we'll have some the table texas
merch um anyways
so glad you were able to join us tonight
and
uh for those of you that are visiting
with us those of you
who are new to the table or
if there's a need we could help you with
whether it's prayer
a listening ear or more tangible
practical needs we would love to be
there for you and i believe sarah will
put up our our contact link where you
can get in touch with us
and you can also find that contact form
on our website at www.thetabletx.org
so usually this is the point where i
send everybody out with a benediction
but i wanted to do something a little
bit different tonight
and share a poem by amina brown that i
thought went
really well with brett's message about
transfiguration and transformation
um and as i was reading through the poem
and listening to brett tonight it
reminded me of
the meet up that gary and i lead we meet
every other week
with a group online and we do
a check-in every time we get together
just to see where everybody's
at what's been happening for uh the last
two weeks
and we usually say something like share
a highlight
a challenge and where you're seeing god
in the midst of it all and the answers
to that question
are my favorite i look forward to
hearing about that every week because i
get to see god through others eyes
and to see god's glory or beauty or
mercy or grace
um through other people's
stories and situations and it's always
so
encouraging and such a reminder that god
is everywhere
even in the most mundane things or even
in our our worst
days or moments so i hope that this poem
uh by amina brown she's a wonderful
wonderful spoken word poet and
performance artist
this is a poem called pentecost and
i hope it inspires you to
look for those glimpses of god's glory
and beauty and goodness uh in your
everyday lives
and i also hope that it inspires you
towards
transfiguration and transformation
through
surrender and awareness and compassion
so this is pentecost
sunrise open eyes
take in breaths through nostrils lungs
every morning moon gives way to sun
making each day a new way to accept
grace
to give and receive forgiveness
to dance in new mercies discover
glimpses of salvation in everyday
conversation
to remember there is magic in childhood
that we don't have to forsake even if we
are no longer children
a chance to put a little wonder in our
pockets and carry it with us
miracles can be found in mud and spit
in the stirring of waters in the shadow
of a mountain
in the ability to go through a hard
thing and survive it
to find awe in the face of everyday
kindness
we are tuning our ear searching for the
right dial
and frequency to hear the voice of god
he is in the silence in the laughter
in the wind he is the light
shining loud and the peace within
he is the explanation and the
unexplained
find him in the mysterious and the
seemingly
mundane in the rhythm of rain
in the feel of the page look closely
and find miracles hidden in every day
you guys have a great week be blessed
stay warm and dry
and i hope to see you back here next
sunday good night
you